a narwhals horn is actually an enlarged
tooth and not a horn at all today we're
talking about narwhals unicorns of the
sea nice shirt
my grandfather Jacques Cousteau studied
and explored the Earth's ocean I do too
and our submarine is in Arctic waters
searching for the narwhal ah he's a
beauty
a narwhals can grow up to 17 feet in
length and their front tooth can grow up
to 10 feet in length it's the only
straight tusk in the world but typically
these are only found on males and are
actually full of up to 10 million nerve
endings helping the narwhal detect
pressure salt levels and even
temperature in the water here's an
interesting fact a narwhal tusk is
flexible it can bend about one foot in
any direction without breaking it was
originally thought that these tusks were
for dueling but a new theory suggests
they're for attracting a mate narwhals
don't migrate like other whale species
they spend their entire lives in icy
Arctic waters hunting squid fish and
crab if you want to see one live you'll
have to come up North because noir walls
don't thrive in captivity rather they
die some animals we humans just can't
tame